a funeral at last for those killed
during anti-un mission protests in
August
after days of negotiating with the
government of the Democratic Republic of
Congo the loved ones of some of those
killed in the protests can bury their
dead
this is a picture of my young boy I'm
wondering why he was killed and why he
deserved to be killed like this God have
mercy on me God have mercy
Charlotte's son was among hundreds
preparing to take part in a band rally
in Goma organized by a Christian
religious sect
calling on U.N peacekeepers to leave
organizers encourage protesters to
overrun U.N bases
they accused menuscal troops of failing
to stop the armed groups in the region
after more than two decades
the crowd was instead met by gunfire by
the Congolese military
the incident was condemned by rights
groups who accused the soldiers of using
excessive force it's also believed that
death toll and the number of people
missing is For Hire
we are here following the court decision
which allowed the victims to be buried
today we have recorded at least 57 tests
and around 40 families close to the
victims have identified the bodies
six soldiers face prosecution in
connection with the killings they've
been charged with crimes against
humanity and violating orders
their trial is being held in a military
Court in North kivu a region battling
the Resurgence of Rebel groups
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera